it's been decades since the land of
wolves had a top hero but there was one
hope got you Sensei
G get out of here with that mess little
mother you ain't no wolf you barely a
dog
run away to beant town again old
head that ain't trash talk this is trash
talk you punk ass
[Music]
mother you not even supposed to s stuff
like that anymore if you not ready to
hear that and you ain't ready for your
test you ain't ready but young would not
be deterred man I show him not ready
super super you see once a year all the
top heroes put aside their differences
for a sacred ritual bring forth the
candidate a ritual to see who is worthy
to make the leap if you make the leap
you will get Untold riches during fans
and various vanity projects such as a
mini golf game show after I made my LEAP
people learned how to pronounce my
name Mel in your last Village you were
the third option at best now Brooklyn
thinks they may finally have a
hero are you ready to take the
leap put your hands up
[Music]
you M's
Bridges Minnesota has suffered too long
without a star hey I will take the leap
sure kid failure to make the leap would
result in falling
off I ain't
worried I will
never I'd like to thank our sponsors the
way of the sub for catering our event
please help
yourself see what a didn't know is that
the leap tests each hero in their own
way
first he had to surpass other
stars then prove he could carry the team
this is a lot easier without
Bev next he had to prove he could carry
himself are you forever you going to
leave us for is there your thank
goodness Rudy a here and the media is
going to get his sound bite one way or
another look y'all know me y'all know my
game I love doing what I'm doing and I
love the land of the wolf even if it
does get a little cold oh so charismatic
and funny
too but could pass the ultimate test
become a Defender how the hell am I
going to beat that or at least look like
one remember what I said I ain't taking
advice from you you didn't want me to do
this that's a training attack that's it
get out of here with that weak ass
that's
mother a here boy wait watch
out remember anything is possible
mother I'mma call you Anthony Edwards Jr
and that's the story of how ant made the
leap and got that dog in him speaking of
dogs in kg one day we woke up to a
three-legged spel and we did not
know where it came from so K knew je was
such a good story 101 I said kg it got
three legs what the hell and he said man
shut the
[Music]
up